Coco is Pixar's new Day of The Dead-themed
animation and the first trailer just dropped
giving us a fantastic look at some of the
characters we can look forward to meeting
in the movie.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and, in this video, I'm doing to break down
the first trailer for Coco and reveal some
hidden details you might have missed.
The trailer opens on a scene of Miguel entering
an ofrenda, or shrine, for his musical hero
Ernesto de la Cruz.
Inside the shrine there are tons of pictures,
records and lots of DLC mentions which, is
of course, short for "De La Cruz", and there's
also two handmade signs that read "DLC Por
Siempre!" which in English means "DLC forever!".
There are lots of nice touches that Pixar
have put into designing this traditional Mexican
ofrenda, in other words, a type of altar set
up on the Day of the Dead to honour the memory
of a person's ancestors.
We can see orange and yellow marigolds, which
are the flowers traditionally used in an ofrenda.
Other cool details include a plate of food
with what looks like a sweet bread or pan
dulce, on top of which is a 'calavera', or
Mexican candied skull.
And that's because, in an ofrenda, the favourite
food of the deceased person is typically offered
to make them feel welcome and comfortable.
Next, Miguel puts on a video cassette of some
old black and white recordings of his idol,
Ernesto de la Cruz, who's voiced by actor
Benjamin Bratt.
You might have seen Bratt on screen recently
as Jonathan Pangborn in Doctor Strange, and
his character in Coco is inspired by legendary
Mexican film and musical icons such as Pedro
Infante, Jorge Negrete and Vicente Fernández.
OK, let's move on to the next scene where
we see Miguel unfolding a torn photo with
the face of one person missing.
What we already know about Coco is that Miguel
comes from a family of shoemakers, the Riveras,
who banned music in the family after Miguel's
great-great-grandmother Imelda was abandoned
by her husband when he left to chase his musical
dreams.
This picture is probably of Miguel's great-great
grandparents and their daughter Mama Coco,
who is Miguel's great-grandmother, and judging
by the broken picture frame on the floor it
seems that Miguel may have chanced upon this
photo literally by accident.
Given this comes straight after the previous
scene of Ernesto de la Cruz on TV serenading
a woman, it seems implied that the missing
character from the photo is the deceased Ernesto.
So, perhaps this photo is the reason why we
next see Miguel breaking into Ernesto's tomb
as he's trying to uncover something about
his family's past.
Inside the tomb, Miguel sees Ernesto's old
guitar, and as he touches it the flowers on
the floor light up suggesting Miguel shares
a special connection with Ernesto.
By the way, this moment and the way the flowers
light up and rise up around him reminds me
somewhat of the 2016 animated movie Kubo And
The Two Strings.
And this special connection is what transports
Miguel to the underworld together with his
dog Dante, who by the way is a Xolo, also
known as a Mexican hairless dog.
Actually, the fact that the dog is named Dante
seems highly appropriate given the themes
of the movie, as medieval Italian poet Dante's
most famous work, The Divine Comedy, is all
about the author's travels through the realms
of the dead.
Finally, the trailer ends with a lovely first
look at the underworld in Coco.
The multi-coloured design and other-worldliness
of it reminded me a bit of Inside Out, which
then left me wondering whether Pixar might
include a cameo by Bing Bong here in the Land
of the Dead.
Bing Bong heroically sacrificed himself to
save Joy from being trapped inside Riley's
Memory Dump and it would be wonderful to see
him or any other deceased Pixar characters
appear in Coco's underworld.
Talking of connections to other Pixar movies,
the inspiration for Coco actually kind of
came from a scene at the end of Toy Story
3.
Coco director Lee Unkrich, who also directed
Toy Story 3, told EW that: "At the end of
Toy Story 3, we had this moment where Jessie
turns on the boom-box and the Gipsy Kings
do a Spanish language version of 'You've Got
a Friend in Me.'
Which, it turned out, ended up being a real
precursor to this movie."
Obviously, there have been Day of the Dead-themed
animations before, including the 2014 film
The Book of Life, but I still can't wait to
see Pixar's own take on the theme.
So, what did you think about the first teaser
trailer for Pixar's Coco?
And are there any dead Pixar characters you'd
like to see appear in Coco's Land of the Dead?
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the comments
below.
And if you enjoyed this video, do please hit
those like and share buttons and why not subscribe
for more of my Pixar and Disney videos?!
You can also tap or click here to watch some
more of my videos you might like!
Thanks for watching and see you next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!